I'm not even doing it man I yeah I do my
research
I never said hog I wasn't cool sorry try
to rule earth I'm sorry about this thing
with the tesseract I just couldn't help
myself I'm a trickster so mischievous
about that time I turned you into a frog
wonderful joke indeed save you let's go
to tell my story
Elvis statue for me who's this big stage
with my helmet on with a big bendy horns
I would say father what you did I didn't
do it for him
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody it's Charlie Hawk I would
be proud of Thor for standing up for him
so if you guys have no idea what's going
on obviously Chris Hemsworth is hanging
out with Matt Damon and they're just
messing around a little bit they shot
this he said it only took one take to
get this to because his Comic Con week
we also have a cool update on guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 aka as guardians of
the galaxy so we'll break it all down
and there's a new round of that imax
ticket giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Thor or Avengers moment on the
video but in case you didn't remember
it's been a hot minute since thor
ragnarok Matt Damon came to do that very
special cameo with Chris Hemsworth's
real-life brother Luke Hemsworth there's
a whole bunch of Hemsworth brothers out
there they're all actors the way they
recorded the audio was kind of janky so
if you couldn't hear what they're
actually saying Chris Hemsworth is just
calling him out for not doing his own
stunts he makes fun of him in the great
wall which was a movie in China that
Matt Damon did a couple of years ago
don't watch it it's a terrible movie but
the character that he plays does a lot
of archery during it so he's just
calling him out for that apparently
because I guess Matt Damon was making
fun of Hawkeye before this so Chris
Hemsworth or just standing up for his
buddy Hawkeye and then Matt Damon just
kind of dejectedly walking away with the
arrow stuck to his forehead I didn't
make fun of Hawkeye I don't know what
you're talking about most of your pie
like wait a minute why are they even in
this video together well Chris Hemsworth
and Matt Damon are friends in real life
they've been friends for a long time so
their family is naturally will go on
vacations together when they're both not
filming movies and my daughter my six
year old got stung by a jellyfish worse
than anything it was the worst thing oh
man I mean even chris said he was like
mate that's the worst thing I've ever
seen so right now Chris Hemsworth is
just taking an extended break from
filming movies because he just did
Avengers end game and he just didn't men
in black international and they just had
their press tours so he was busy for
most of this year he said he's just
taking some time off to be with his
family
Matt Damon also between movies is just
visiting him in Australia the story of
how he actually wound up in Thor
Ragnarok is kind of funny too he said
that Chris Hemsworth just called me up
Tyco called me up and I'm friends with
those guys they pitched me the idea
thought it was hysterical the idea is
basically an intergalactic community
theater actor kind of living out Tom
Hiddleston's characters fantasy I just
thought it was a great funny bit and
easy to do those guys were a lot of fun
and Tycho runs a really fun set it was a
light lift for me so they film that
stuff pretty quickly and if you've
listened to the commentary track from
thor ragnarok Taika Waititi doesn't say
a whole lot specifically about casting
them he just makes a lot of jokes about
tyke averse crossover with the Marvel
Universe because a lot of these other
actors like Sam Neill have also starred
in his other non Marvel films Anthony
Hopkins in the same I told him you are
going to be playing Tom Hiddleston
[Music]
playing you and he said okay good and
they turned up in blue eyeliner Matt
Damon I don't know if you guys
recognized him from We Bought a Zoo
that's him the little crossover there
little Marvel We Bought a Zoo crossover
so pretty much everybody in this scene
just wind up doing this because they're
either friends with Chris Hemsworth or
tyka in real life I don't recall them
saying anything about whether or not
Matt Damon and Luke Hemsworth as
guardians characters were killed by
Thanos in Thor ship at the beginning of
Avengers infinity war or whether they
got snapped and then brought back by the
Hulk snap and Avengers end game because
otherwise there's a Matt Damon Asgardian
walking around new Asgard being a
fisherman like the rest of those as
Guardians living on earth now just
imagine Matt Damon showing up in
somebody's random movie when they go
back to new Asgard like I said though
because it's comic-con week there's a
bunch of Marvel phase 4 news flying
around James Gunn recently made some
announcements about guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 clarifying a little bit
about what's going on with Thor and as
guardians of the galaxy as you would
expect he gets a lot of spam DMS from
crazy fans asking him for details on the
movie this one seemingly freaking out
that they're gonna suddenly start
calling the guardians of the galaxy
movies as guardians of the galaxy
because Thor might be in them James Gunn
actually answers which is surprising
saying don't worry seemingly confirming
that the title of guardians of the
galaxy 3 will not be as guardians of the
galaxy which I don't think is that huge
of a surprise guardians of the galaxy is
still a huge brand for Marvel so
regardless of what the plot is they're
not going to suddenly change the name
no matter who they put in the movie and
it also clarifies a little bit about
Chris Hemsworth's involvement in the
movie is Thor in what they meant by that
Avengers end game end credits scene
where they're joking about who's really
in charge of the new Guardians team now
should fight one another for the honor
of losing me yes for calling the team as
guardians of the galaxy together again
as if they're old pals they're gonna be
suddenly journeying together all the
time now and then making you wonder
whether or not he was really going to be
calling the shots the big joke being
that the Guardians seemed like they
could go either way in terms of a leader
like oh yeah Thor seems pretty awesome
maybe you should fight each other with
knives for the honor
but based on what James Gunn is saying
it sounds like it's still gonna be a
Guardians film with maybe a little bit
of Thor in it so my expectations for
Thor may be just assisting them a little
bit with their Adam warlock problem and
possibly serving as a narrative bridge
to introduce the beta ray bill character
into the franchise beta ray bill is
still only a rumor right now but he just
joined the Guardians team in the comics
this past year if you didn't listen to
any of the big interviews around Thor
Ragnarok they said that they had big
plans for the character originally
during that movie when they were in the
Sekar scenes in the arena but they said
that they just got to be too much Kevin
Feige said that they decided that they
would just save the character for a
meteor role in a future movie so that's
how his face wound up on the side of the
Grand Master's tower so that just means
that they are planning on introducing
beta ray bill at some point and because
he's such a weird character I mean he
looks kind of like a talking humanoid
horse
what better film to introduce him in
than the guardians of the galaxy if they
can totally make you buy into the idea
of a talking tree and a talking raccoon
as a character they can totally get you
to buy into beta ray bill right now
they're not scheduled to start shooting
that movie till later next year they
might mention something about it during
Marvel's phase 4 at Comic Con panel next
week I'm only expecting them to announce
the next three to four years worth of
movies but right now the expected
release date for guardians of the galaxy
3 is 2021 after that Chris Hemsworth
said that he really wants to do Thor 4
and Tycho wants to come back to direct
another Marvel movie but the actual plot
of
that film will just depend on where they
leave the Thor character after any as
guardians of the galaxy adventures that
he has during guardians 3 obviously if
you're killed it'll be your last but you
don't know if you're killed or not if
you're not do you think you'll do
another one
you look as far as this is sort of
Marvel's phase 3 wrapping up a
combination of all that this journey
whether or not they go off and then
shoot other things I do prequels or
sequels or whatever they can do I mean
Loki my brothers come back nine times we
told guys just keep appearing so who
knows what since or anyone it me
personally it's the best fun I've ever
had and I'd be happy to do more so they
wanted me but so let me know in the
comments what do you want them to do
with Thor in the Marvel Universe
if he stays mostly in space for Marvel
phase four think about the spider-man
far from home post credits scene with
Nick Fury on the sword Space Station
that means that when they get ready for
Avengers 5 they can actually do it more
is a space-based film Thor doesn't even
have to come back to Planet Earth to do
that I think part of the reason for
doing that post credit scene is to let
you know that the really big Avengers
level stuff is gonna be happening mostly
in outer space and they can keep the
more grounded character movies on earth
say like spider-man so we can get much
bigger
but he won't be overshadowed by Avengers
doing stuff on planet earth because
they'll be busy in outer space there was
a lot more Marvel phase 4 movie news
there was some Dark Avengers Young
Avengers stuff going around so I'll
probably do a video about that at some
point leave your requests in the
comments below click here for that
spider-man far from home Fantastic Four
Easter Egg video and click here for my
spider-man 3 teaser video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you